hi there and thanks so much for joining
us today my name is bradley knapp with
ibm and today the topic that we're going
to talk about is desktop virtualization
and this is a topic that's gotten a
whole lot of press very recently because
of some recent announcements in the
field but i just want to give a very
brief overview of what is this desktop
virtualization thing and how could it
potentially help you
or your company so if we think about
desktop virtualization holistically
we've got to go back in time and really
not that far in time or even to the
present day
where we have a person
right that person
pretty much no matter what his job is
there's going to be some level of
computing involved right so that guy is
going to have his laptop
and he's going to be typing away at the
laptop maybe he's got a desktop but
computing is integrated into everything
that we do and so if you think about
that from a business perspective that
means that businesses have to buy and
issue and secure
thousands or tens or thousands or
hundreds of thousands of physical
computing devices and there's obviously
some risk that comes along with that
right if you've got a laptop it can be
stolen
if you've got a desktop you know they're
anchored to the desk they're not going
to wander off on their own but you're
leaving it unattended all the time so
you've got a risk if you haven't
properly secured it someone can get in
and get to that physical machine and do
things they're not supposed to
that's on the information worker side
but let's also think about a factory
floor or let's think about a hospital or
let's think about a school
where you've got to maintain
all of these computing devices some of
which are in kind of rough environments
right kids are not the most gentle folks
on the planet and factory production
floors aren't either
and so computers are for better or for
worse somewhat delicate devices so we've
got to take care of them
and in addition to that you've got the
security headache of securing not just
the physical machines but also securing
all of the user accounts for them
securing them against penetration
against theft against loss
and so we have to think a little bit
about is there a better way is there a
way where we can centralize more so we
don't have to buy as much hardware or if
we do have to buy as much hardware we
can buy less expensive hardware so can
we centralize it can we lower our costs
and can we do it in a more secure manner
when somebody's got an individual laptop
they can install software on it
generally speaking and there's always a
possibility that that software
can cause some sort of a security
vulnerability there have been lots of
great published presentations as of late
about software that gets installed onto
a local machine that inadvertently
causes much greater security problems so
how do we fix these problems
and one way certainly not the only way
but one way is to do desktop
virtualization where the desktop rather
than running on the local machine
running on that physical machine itself
we are going to run it remotely we're
going to run it in the cloud
and so
instead of a physical high-powered
laptop
let's imagine
that we've got 10 architects in an
architect firm architects need high-end
machines right they do lots of
processing lots of cad work they need
very powerful processors they need lots
of ram they need graphics acceleration
so to buy each one of them a very
powerful laptop which by the way is not
terribly portable
we're going to have to spend a lot of
money is there an alternative there is
desktop virtualization so let us imagine
a physical server
cloud server sitting in a data center
we'll call that server there we go
now this server is 20 or 30 or 50 times
more powerful from a compute performance
perspective than this laptop
but it can perform all of the same
functions you can put the same graphics
accelerators in it you can stuff them
full of ram so that it can get
equivalent or better performance
but it's in a data center how useful is
that well the answer is you take this
server and you divide it up into
virtual machines
that each machine is a virtual desktop
so you get a virtual desktop
for each one of your individual users
and you get to stack them on top of this
server so one piece of physical
infrastructure can host 4 or 10 or 20 or
concurrent desktop sessions
well why is this good well let's imagine
a 24-hour workplace
notice i said concurrent desktop
sessions before
so if you've got users that are working
24 7 365 like it's say a hospital
rather than having to have a laptop for
each one of them they just get a session
well if you've got a thousand employees
and they work about 500 during the day
and about 500 at night you only have to
size your infrastructure to run for 500
people plus a little bit of overhead so
you're going to save money because
you're going to increase density you're
also going to be able to take all of
these big expensive enterprise benefits
but you only have to buy half as many
right because you are serving multiple
users out of that same physical machine
now
let's go back to our hospital for for a
moment here hospital you've got a nurse
who's walking around she's got a certain
number of patients four six eight
patients right
and maybe each room in that hospital has
its own computer
right so you've got a physical device
there it's not a powerful device because
all it does is host these virtual
sessions up here
well as that nurse goes from room to
room to room she doesn't want to lose
whatever she's working on she's got all
of the stuff that she's already doing
plus what she's going to be doing in
that next room this is another place
where virtual desktops are really cool
right so let's call this this box right
here this is going to be her session
this is her concurrent session
so she's in room one
and she logs in on that machine to her
user session and so she's got her email
running she's got the the patient
records open she's got lab records open
maybe some x-rays something like that
and so that is all running in this
session that is unique to her now
she gets done in that room and it's time
for her to physically go over to room
number two now
all she has to do is disconnect this
session right here so we'll put an x on
it and reconnect from the computer in
room number two but the session is
stateful it's still live and so nothing
has changed on the screen that is
displayed to her even though she's now
on a different physical device she's
logged in on a whole new machine now and
she can do that as she goes to room
three
and four and so on and so forth because
the session
is running on the server it's running in
the cloud she doesn't ever have to
log off and log back on again and
rebuild the machine like if you were
going in an old school environment where
you logged off a machine and then you
would have to reload it off the domain
because it the actual desktop itself all
of the applications on the desktop are
residing on that server all she's doing
is accessing her session
so not only do you get the increased
density which is a great thing lowers
cost you also get this concurrency of
session which is great for your
employees because they aren't constantly
logging out and logging in and logging
out and logging in
and moving from place to place to place
another place that virtual desktops are
great let's imagine something like a
call center environment where you don't
have assigned seating right the
employees come in they sit down wherever
they need to be they log in and they
start work
well
because these sessions reside on the
server whenever you bring them up they
can be brought up onto any client right
and so the ability to bring up any
client is important bring up on any
clients is very important because now
you don't have to worry about the
problems of assigned sitting and this
person can only sit in this cube because
it's the only one that is authorized to
bring up their session so again the
increased flexibility that you get is
just fantastic now
there's one other really neat part about
virtual desktops that's very specific to
security that i do want to touch on so
let us imagine for a moment
a scenario where you've got security
information right information that needs
to be heavily protected against loss
and so we've got our guy over here he's
got his laptop he's working at home but
he needs to get into this secured
information and for various internal
reasons he is not allowed to access that
information and store it on his local
machine
what he can do is he can create a
session out of his local machine
into our server
and he can open a virtual desktop on his
physical desktop it runs in a window
just like any other window so he can
create a session
that is going to display to him that
secured information but it's going to
display it in a secured way right
because he's not caching it locally on
his machine it can't be stolen off of it
all he's seeing is an image of what he's
looking at and that image is delivered
via the secure server so again helping
to ensure security helping to ensure
access control making sure that only the
right people are getting to the
documents that they need to get to
so that's a really brief overview of
virtual desktops hopefully it was useful
and if you have any questions just let
us know
you